[Music]
I'm
moving
already I feel all of the energy that
I'm going to feel I feel it already in
my body my body is matter so it has
energy so I'm moving moved off the line
sh
so for example if I do the the technique
you did and he could run out of
that he just runs out of
it but if I C you project I cut down
here and this CQ projection I'll leave
that hand off this cou projection is
going that
way so you have this hand coming around
you and then
this hand going that
way so you now have an x pattern but
it's not with my body not on for example
here the x pattern was my my hand going
this way and my St going this way okay
this
time go this hand going
here this way this hand going that way
and you have the
X
so if you want to know what to look
for you have to feel
Muk on an acceleration roll where UK
decides to just
roll his roll goes right where his foot
is now that's just roll here he's right
there his foot will always go right into
the
[Music]
roll in the CL you not
he's his foot as I said is going to be
the launching pad for his Center and
he does not get to roll by his feet I
don't know if you caught did you okay so
you you can do those any any
way see any any
way it's got like this
though you keep
projecting even here you can do
it okay let's go so I can do
T where I have the one Topsy tury and
then the
physical other Topsy tury you understand
oh but you can still
do the same X just like you're going
doet right we kind of do what you guys
are
doing you can still
do you see the difference okay